il ne porte plus le même maillot et
pourtant il continue de frapper dans le
même ballon mais sur un parcours de golf
avec des chaussettes hautes un gilet et
un béret vous êtes au football les
règles sont celles du golf sauf qu'ici
pas de club seulement des pieds pour
faire entrer le ballon dans un trou de
55 cm de diamètre en un minimum de coût
pas si facile même quand on a marqué
près de 100 buts dans sa carrière de
football
ça parait simple ça parait été simple à
vue on a l'impression que que c'est très
simple mais finalement les distances
sont relativement faussées par rapport
aux hommes un terrain de foot ou c'est
beaucoup plus rapproché là c'est il y a
la distance c'est dur à jauger et après
bon il y a forcément le terrain pas
facile faut frapper on a toujours peur
de se blesser mais c'est très sympa
ouais Neo Pays-Bas en 2009 la discipline
compte désormais 16 fédérations dans le
monde l'Argentine a d'ailleurs remporté
la première Coupe du monde en 2012 et la
prochaine pourrait bien être organisée
en France mais pour cela les fous de
golfeurs doivent d'abord être accepté
sur les greens fin 2014 on espère avoir
2500 licenciés et à horizon 2-3 ans
c'est d'avoir entre 5 et 10 000
licenciés qui puissent voilà commencer à
pratiquer on sait que pour ça de toute
façon ça passe par le fait que les que
certains golf nous acceptent pour une
pratique régulière parce que bon venir
jouer comme ça une fois c'est marrant
c'est ludique mais c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il y en a qui peuvent s'y
prendre se prendre au jeu et commencer à
avoir envie de jouer régulièrement comme
au golf ou comme au foot trois golf
viennent de signer un partenariat avec
l'Association Française de Football pour
accueillir ce nouveau sport les Pays-Bas
venus en masse à Feucherolles ont marqué
leur territoire en remportant l'épreuve
par équipe de cette première étape de la
Food Golf Cup 2014